خلال 24 ساعه انهارت ثروه الشاب الثلاثيني
سان باكمان فرايدا مؤسس بورصه العملات
المشفره اف تي اكس بنحو 94% في نوفمبر
الماضي رقم كارثي ادخل منصه التداول
ومؤسسها من اضيق ابواب التاريخ باعتباره
اكبر انخفاض تم التسجيله على الاطلاق في
مؤشر بلومبرج للملياردات وبين عشيه وضحاها
وبعد ان ترك باتمان اكثر من مليون موده
حاجزين عن سحب اموالهم يبدو ان غضبهم لجم
قليلا مع نبا اعتقال شرطه جزر قلبها لمؤسس
من الصعب واكد المدعي العام الامريكي
للمنطقه الجنوبيه نيويوركانيا وليامز
الاعتقال وقال ان الخطوه اتخذت بناء على
طلب من الحكومه الامريكيه واضاف ان لائحه
التهام المقدمه ستكشف في الوقت المناسب
[موسيقى]
ذاك الشاب الذي كان ينظر اليه على انه حصن
امين بات منبوذا بعد ان عانت شركته من
ازمه سيوله وتقدمت بطلب للافلاسه وحصل
الافلاس بعد تعثر منصه تداول العملات في
جمع المليارات لدرء لانهيار بعد ان سارع
المتداولون لسحب سته مليارات دولار منها
خلال 72 ساعه فقط اثر علمهم بعمليه احتلال
انهيار امبراطوريه افت اكس يرجعهم محللون
بسبب الاختفاء المفاجئ للاموال علما بان
باتمان حول سرا 10 مليارات دولار من اموال
العملاء من افتي اكس الى الميده تزامنا مع
اختفاء اكثر من مليار دولار من اموال
العملاء وفي الشهاده مكتوبه قال الرئيس
التنفيذي الجديد لشركه اف تي اكس المعين
من قبل المحكمه جونراي الثالث ان تبدد من
الصلاه لم يكن الا بسبب التركيز المطلق
للسيطره في اي مجموعه صغيره جدا من
الافراد غير المتمارسين وليسوا اصحاب خبره
مضيفا ان بنك مان سمح لشركه ابحاث الاميدا
باقتراضي اموال من بورصه العملات المشفره
بلا اي قيود فعله
[موسيقى]